[Music]
i've never seen anything like it the
fire equivalent of an ice age like
peering into dante's inferno and it's
only going to accelerate
it's only beginning
we're surrounded by fire
my dad put his hand on my shoulder and
he said don't leave whatever you do do
not let that building burn down evacuate
everything was on fire the looks on
their faces they were sure they were
gonna die run for your life i've never
seen that look in anybody's face
the world is waking up to the hellish
realization that all over this planet
wildfires are burning us alive
most the people i know
lost everything
and that's why we came to be embedded
with firefighters on what turned out to
be the deadliest day for fires in
california yet again two years in a row
we're caught with our pants down you're
left making decisions you don't want to
make
it was difficult very difficult
private firefighters protect people with
money bring your own brigade
if we're war of fire we're going to
spend a lot of money we're going to take
a lot of casualties and we're going to
lose
and i still don't think the public
understands that
[Music]
your outsider perspective on this was
the first thing i wanted to ask you
about because i have covered
i am i grew up in california i've been a
journalist in california and i felt like
oh fire i totally know everything that
there is to know about this but this
film had so much
new
different information and such just a
critically different perspective and i
say it as a new yorker of course you're
not but i love that line when if whoever
it was assumed that you were a new
yorker but wait a minute are you from
new york i i actually was born in new
york but i grew up out here that's that
was the line wait a minute are you from
new york
and i'm just curious what you think you
were able to bring to this project by
nature of the fact that you are not from
this country you are not from california
you did not grow up with fire in the
same way that we here have grown up with
fire
oh my gosh that's such a good question
except i feel like the film answered
that and i'm like what do you think that
i brought to it um
and we should step back by the way
because we don't have maeve with us we
have our amazing maeve um
the incredible firefighter who you just
met
she would have been here tonight with us
um and she sends her regrets but her
one of her kids just tested positive for
covert and she didn't want to
risk it um
uh
so
she couldn't be here so i think she was
advertised
and now you're stuck with us
um
i mean
it's hard to say what i brought to it
right but i always think that um
[Music]
i hope it's not the obvious stuff
because i don't think we need to to make
a film about the stuff that we know
already that's always true
um
i just knew with this film that i
it was a film that was perhaps
unlike some of my other films it wasn't
driven by
an idea of what could be a really great
finished film
it was more driven by this
determination to actually really get to
the bottom of
what was happening and to really answer
this question for myself
um of what was going on with this
landscape because i didn't understand it
and
the commitment i had was to
[Music]
just um keep going until i really felt
like i had my arms around that
and that's the film and it's kind of a
hairy um
uh
you know shaggy dog story in a way right
it it structurally it just kind of
you know
follows
what needs to happen i feel
um
and
it turned out that the truth was
awkwardly complicated
um i didn't want to
shortchange that i didn't want to make
reality simpler than it is
um
and i felt like i had to honor the
answer that i found
um
and so i don't know if that's my
outsider perspective for just my um
uh
awkward
integrity
probably and i think that's outsiders
and i think that's just
yeah
um
a kind of refusal to simplify
when
the commitment was to the truth the
situation the truth the situation was
the complexity that i found in the story
that it wasn't just
climate change it wasn't just one thing
and when you pulled on that thread
really
what you discovered was a whole lot
about how we're living in the world
today
and
that told me everything about how we're
living in the world today and it wasn't
just about fire but i'm a bit jet-lagged
so we should ask more specific questions
because otherwise i'll just ramble very
very vaguely well i will say that what i
thought because you asked you know what
did we think
of your outsider perspective and i think
what this film what was so revelatory to
me was what and especially i have to say
with the timing of it coming out in the
midst of a pandemic is how deeply
american we can be
and how sometimes
that explains a lot you know and
sometimes defies certain logic and and
i'm curious as you watch this story
unfold and you started peeling away the
layers of it all and for example that
that city council meeting where they say
nope five feet defensible space nope not
going to do it what it was like for you
as a filmmaker to get to that level of
understanding what a uniquely
american perspective
led us to the place that we're in now
well i will say that i've never been in
any of my films i've never rated any of
my films i've certainly never
put a shot of myself and of course i
wasn't intending to use that shot of
myself
um
it just so happened the camera was
pointing that way at one point and that
was the only few frames we had of me
but i felt like that was the best way of
um
telling the story of that moment was to
include my
face in that moment because it was such
a heavy moment for me
i think a lot about the tension between
individualism and
[Music]
what you might call socialism depending
on where you
where you feel
uh your political allegiances lie but um
no but you know that that tension
between um the individual and the
community you know i think my first film
was about amish people trying to decide
whether to be amish which is kind of the
ultimate non-individualistic
um community in the us um or
american which is kind of the ultimate
individual you know um
path in this world right now
and
several of my films have been about that
i did a film
my second film blindside was about
um blind people climbing mount everest
but what it was really about
um was about
a team of
german educators american mountaineers
and tibetan students
all going up everest together and having
a kind of giant moment of culture clash
culminating in a really fantastic
argument at 23 000 feet
um
about how we relate to mountains
and whether to climb up them or
not and
whether one person should stand on top
or whether
you know you should
build a school instead or something so
it was very
much about that culture clash and i
think as a european who's moved to the
u.s
and left my own kind of family and
culture behind i think that i think i
think about this a lot
about the genetics of what it takes to
leave um
and i felt like you know
i think there was also something it
wasn't just about the fact that we
finished this film during the pandemic
it was also that we finished the film
during this moment where i think we're
really um
[Music]
in this moment of um
with the george floyd murder that we're
all trying to sort of examine our own
responsibility
in the
um
uh landscape that we're in
and really think about what it means to
be
european and and i i i sort of feel like
in that way as well bringing my own
status as an outsider but as a
specifically european who'd come to
california
um
kind of examining that was um a moment
to do that as well
the film covers so much and one of the
things that i found that was very
different from the typical in that
moment fire coverage is the focus on the
firefighters themselves and and i'm
wondering if you could talk a little bit
about you know when in the midst of
looking at all these different angles
and perspectives you landed on i need to
spend time here as well and how you got
them because you know i've talked with a
lot of firefighters these are often men
and women who don't like to show any
sign of weakness so to get them to open
up about what they were really facing
just how devastating it was how that it
could
ruin marriages how you were able to get
to that point with them
well actually the um
inspiration for making the film had come
from
um
having friends
who were involved both as firefighters
and residents
in the thomas fire which was a reference
at the beginning of the narration where
i started this film was
the thomas fire which is four years ago
um
exactly this time of year was um
the at the time largest fire ever in
california and now it's only the seventh
largest four years later which i think
tells you a lot about how
rapidly
these fires are getting worse
and
[Music]
i had friends
in ohio and santa barbara as residents
and as firefighters and it was so
dramatic what they were going through
and i just kept thinking why is there
not a film about this so i was always
very
acutely aware of the trauma and
drama and
intensity of what was being experienced
from both the firefighters and the
residents i don't think there was a time
when i wasn't aware of that
and maybe it was my neighbor tay
but or my experience with other
situations where i've always managed to
kind of get access to that um
that people have um
in my experience filming with them been
very generous
when what you are interested in is the
truth of the situation that they're
experiencing i've really
[Music]
been blown away by
people's generosity in sharing
these incredibly
painful intimate
emotional
truths of their lives
because
they
seem to know that
the story
will really
um benefit
others by being shared honestly
and if you can find that
frequency with people
they'll
stun you with their
candor
and
eloquence and
i found that true here too
i didn't have any
challenge with people
opening up in fact i think and it's a
shame we don't have maeve to speak to
this here today because the firefighters
who seen the film
i think have said like why has no one
told this story before
and when i think about the
sort of adulation that we shower
firefighters with right they're our
heroes and culturally there are the
pinups
of the people that we admire as they
should be because um
really they're just
i was in awe of them before i made this
and um
my appreciation of them only ever grew
when i spent time with them up close i
just couldn't believe what incredibly
generous
[Music]
creatures they are they only if you want
to torture a firefighter ask them about
something where they wanted to help more
and they feel like they should have
helped more you know they only want to
help us more
to such an extraordinary degree and
people talk about you know yay
firefighters all the time but when you
see that town council meeting and you
see the paradise fire chief
explaining
um so clearly
the reality
of his job
and that nobody does actually listen to
their experience
um or help them do that job that they're
dying
to to do for us to save us
and so for me that the kind of
cognitive dissonance of that you know
just
for me i just sort of want to get in
there and point that out you know that
that's what's
that that's the truth of their
experience is that that and and
i think that's so easy in this world to
kind of feel like we can keep consuming
we can keep building we can keep
growing we can keep inflating we can
keep having this world that shines more
and more right
and that there isn't a cast and the cast
you know when you talk to the
firefighters and you understand what
their lives are like you start to
understand where
this inflation is
taking you know
its fuel from or whatever and
in their quality of life or in their
actual lives and uh in in terms of their
lives um taken in in their work and
stuff i really am jet lagged so
um help me with some practical questions
but um yeah but i wish the firefighters
were because the firefighters will say
this is the first film that's talked
about what life is like for us and
they're really um
and i kind of look around and think why
is nobody told that story because
there's been tons of like smoke jumpers
yay kind of stuff and it is it's pretty
[ __ ] excuse my language fun to watch
the they're really like amazing action
figures right but i think this stuff um
seems very intuitive it seems very
obvious to me
but
we live in a culture where one we don't
have much of a threshold for pain or
discomfort and
we do quick we do quick really really
really well i think and one of the
things i found remarkable about the city
council scene was when they said let's
just remember what it was like that day
which i think asked me to leads me to a
very practical question for you about
the beginning part of this film um
when i watched it you know the the good
folks who organized this evening said i
would just it's the first time i've ever
actually as a moderator gotten kind of a
trigger warning like
be aware the first half hour is really a
lot and i was like oh it's fire i've
covered every one of these fires since
2003. and yet i really felt like sitting
with fire
in that way which i think really goes to
show the power of documentary it's not a
tweet it's not a 5 pm newscast it's not
an l.a times story can you talk a little
bit about your choices about that
opening of the movie and especially
sitting with so much of it so much of
the peril and so much of the pain for so
long because it definitely had an impact
i think for everything you saw going
forward
so much to say um
uh
i didn't want to kind of traumatize
people for the sake of showing off my
filmmaking skills you know it's all too
easy to take material like that which is
so intense and make it look intense you
know because it is inherently um
uh
extraordinary um what people suffered
and now with um
the cameras that we have you know the
amazing coverage that we have of these
disasters
with people's smartphones
um because most of that footage was not
shot by us although some of it was most
of it was stuff that people would like
airdrop to me when i met them
or um like the 9-1-1 course we got
through freedom of information requests
the radio traffic you can um you can
pull this stuff as matters of public
record right and we come through
myself and the editors come through a
lot of it and it was really
sad work you know to do that
but i always felt that
it was important to understand and
communicate what it was really like
in those incidents
and
so as i picked through this morass of
material trying to think about what to
include
i wanted to include the pieces that
would really empower the audience
to then understand
the kind of investigation moving forward
about what i felt were the interesting
and important pieces
and usually the non-obvious pieces but
the um
i wanted
um
the audience to experience the the
confusion the kind of fog of war of it
all the
lack of information the speed
um
the fact that so many lives were saved
by individual acts of
creativity
and desperation
and
the wind blowing one way or the other
could make all the difference and and so
on and so on
you know and that lives were lost and
lost in those specific ways that they
were and the firefighters are tired and
their shifts are 24 hours and just some
of the the facts on the ground of those
things and that people do stay and
defend and
um the people that you meet did live to
tell those tales and um so forth so i
kind of wanted you
to sort of understand what i'd learned
about this situation
um
and um
it was extraordinary making the film
because i kind of felt like
i spoke to so many people and i'd
gathered so many stories that i felt
like um
it was
a weird i felt like i knew what happened
on every block of the incident
particularly in paradise
um i'd spoken to so many people i knew
i'd heard the anecdotes from eight
different people who'd never met each
other you know but i knew about the
stopped truck full of soda that
different people at different points
during the morning had stopped and
gotten the soda off the back of that
truck because the the cans were just
sitting there and they were thirsty or
whatever it was you know
and i knew the dozer driver has never
met the guy that he rescued i
interviewed them separately and and
pieced together who that was and tracked
them all down right so
it kind of to feel like you had
done so much
um
insane amount of research
that um
you
had this
strange
kind of god-like perspective on the
whole chess board of this incident
um because it wasn't obvious what were
the important elements i think the
reporting on afar is getting better and
better
but even um
at the beginning of making this film it
wasn't as
well understood as we're starting to get
to it now i think we're starting to
understand this this more and more it's
being better reported the logging story
is still not been reported
um
but other pieces of it you know but but
there were loads of theories that were
bogus i mean some are obviously bogus
like laser pointers and the conspiracy
theories are easy to dismiss but there
are other theories as well that seemed
to hold water and gelato really examined
them and so my job was to really
and i was really trying to
understand what were the important
pieces of the story to
to see and then to share
um
so it was a lot of work what can i say
about that and but the but the pieces
that i kept
were the pieces that i felt would would
equip the audience the best to take the
journey of the rest of the film
the point was never to
just have that immersion and terror at
the beginning the the point was
to set you up so that when you see that
town council meeting you understand
why
it's amazing
that less than a year after that
incident
that community
would not do
free things
you know cost-free things
to not have that happen again
that's that's the journey that you're
taking on so you have to start there to
set that up to pay that off
well i think there's a coda too which is
where i'd like to end our chat tonight
as well because i think at the beginning
there's there is such pure terror and
horror from the destruction
that fire causes and that's how we tend
to think of it fire bad right
but at the end and i love i believe it
was the you know the japanese poem about
how the fire destroys the house but now
i have this view and i'm curious in the
making of it and especially that that
kind of those final chapters
if your attitude about fire where you
sit with it
right now when you think why is this
something that happens not from a
factual okay here's clear cutting here's
climate change but like the big why the
spiritual why the existential why oh
don't get me out of the spiritual why my
gosh i am
i go i go
um far out on this virtual y
i don't know if we should go there we
get in with a little spiritual far out
well
i kind of it's in the end somewhat right
and i just isn't it incredible
the indigenous cultural practitioners in
this you know i was on a panel recently
with deadline magazine
with trina and don who are in the film
and they just spoke so beautifully about
their work
and
their work so amazing and i thought my
god i must be doing something right if
i'm
they're getting to talk about their work
with this um hollywood audience i felt
so
moved um
to help give them you know the platform
um because i think what they're doing is
so brilliant but
um
you know for me you know
far is the landscape breathing you know
and um
[Music]
it's what we've forgotten as a culture
you know which is rest which is
um
[Music]
renewal
and um
and
[Music]
so i i don't know i i i could go very
deep on that but i i've thought a lot
about it and it's been
an incredible opportunity making this
film to think from all the different
angles about this fire issue i mean
there's so many things and i'm sure as
audience you know there's so many
different sort of things to think about
or that i got obsessed with at different
points making the film you know like
what would you take what
what of your belongings means anything
um or you know when fire burns
everything away you know it is
extraordinary that it kind of fire burns
off and you reveals
you know the
bones of your life you know when
fire takes
your house
you really see what um people are made
of you know and what their lives are
made of and so all these different kind
of
things i was um
reflecting upon when i was making the
film
and
um perhaps you see that
i was really interested in all this
stuff along the way when you watch the
film
lucy thank you so much for bringing your
own brigade and for your time tonight
really appreciate it oh thank you
at the end the last thing i was going to
say is um
uh if people i wasn't sure if the
audience was going to get to ask
questions but since they weren't you can
always um
reach us at lucy walker film i'm at lucy
walker film if you ever have any
questions or want to
spread word about the film or ask
anything more please be in touch and
thank you so much for being here it's
really
amazing to be in real life so thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you